dawn asks Gary I'm ten years old which
one of your book should I read first and
when should I read it I can't decide Don
first of all big shout out to you
because at 10 years old I had read zero
books in my life so I appreciate you
debating the three books you know
actually for you you know I probably
just start with Jab Jab Jab right hook I
mean I think the Thank You economy I
think jab - jab right hook in a lot of
ways is a modern version of crush it
with less kind of oomph and like rah rah
and hype so if you want to get pumped
that you're at your you know 120 months
of existence then crush it is
interesting I think Thank You economy is
probably the one I want most in your
veins and your religion so that I might
even say for last but Jab Jab Jab right
hook has modern-day execution of what
crush it is you're gonna really
understand it better than a lot of
people in the vaynernation because
you're so much in a place where you're
growing up native to the digital
communication world so I go Jab Jab
right hook crush it
Thank You economy